please welcome jaden michael
i am so excited to meet you i have been
looking forward to this i
watched every single second
of the entire season
i mean it's incredible what was even
just like the casting process like
finding out about the project how did it
get on your radar it was a very normal
casting process
it was just another audition and another
audition and i remember being like oh
man whoever gets to do this role is
going to have a lot of fun
and i was like oh wait
it's me
and
casting processes are so
weird you get online
like imagine like trying to convince
someone like hey i'm perfect for your
new movie
i can't see you though what's funny is
you have to do so much convincing as
colin
so in a weird way i think it's a good
kind of energy parlay
i just okay first of all ava duvernay
might be one of my biggest heroes on the
planet
and she co-created this with colin
kaepernick and then you even have
filmmakers like robert townsend in there
who i mean hollywood shuffle and raw
i've been such a fan of his since i was
a kid i was so happy
to see him a part of this project
it's a very interesting
project in the way that it mixes
if it was art you would call it mixed
media you know it takes a lot of
different formats and genres
and ties them all together in a way i
haven't seen before i remember ava
telling me she was like listen this is
either going to really work or really
not work so it's a risk it was a race
yeah it really is
what was your feelings about colin
before you even knew this project
existed
he was a role model for me um you know
my family they they love football and um
so i had known about his career his 2014
season 2015 season
um but i i wasn't a huge sports guy so i
wasn't like
as invested as my family was but when i
saw him kneeling
it completely changed how i looked at
him and how i viewed him it was like
you know
it's not often that you see
an athlete um choose to
you know i feel like athletes are sort
of told to
focus on your craft focus on your on
your athleticism be an athlete and he
sort of said no i i think it's more
important to stand up and speak for for
people who don't have a voice and to me
i've always been someone who thought it
was important to if you have any sort of
influence over any group you should use
it for change for positive change and he
perfectly embodies that so
i certainly think in any industry if
somebody goes out on these limbs of
protests it just can destroy your career
and so
it is the riskiest thing you can do
and he
changed the world
with what he did i think that's the
the main thing i want to say to the
audience um the true audience is
the people who don't understand him yet
the people who misunderstand and
misinterpret what his meeting is and um
i think i wanted to build a call in that
could be
edible for for different people people
who have different political point of
views and even if you don't agree with
his politics if you don't agree with how
he carried out his politics how he
expressed himself how he stood up for
other people maybe you can come to
respect the amount of selflessness that
he had and
he
he was
he lost everything oh yeah and that's
what i find so devastating and even
though you see other athletes taking
knees
and getting in on the movement he's
still seen as an outcast yeah and i
don't understand that he's staged
workouts he's staged um you know uh
countless uh exercises
demonstrating his complete ability to
continue being a quarterback he has all
of the ability to continue doing his job
but he's being held back from doing it i
just want to see him play again also
like i just who's not going to want to
make some competition
like get him back in the game like let's
move forward and what i do appreciate
about what you're saying is i went into
it and even this conversation with some
trepidation because there are people out
there that have completely different
views uh there's a patriotism there's a
political viewpoint he is a patriot
though that's what i don't understand
absolutely the ultimate um sign of
patriotism is standing up for what you
believe in whatever your beliefs are can
we take violence and judgment and so
much anger out of it and have the
ability to listen to each other and um
all of that aside you are so good in
this role i stayed up all night long
binging this
show and although it is such an
important piece of art
um and so meaningful and so impactful
i mean i could not take my eyes off of
you your emotionality your performance i
noticed things like how small and short
you seemed because by the next two
episodes you seem taller and towering
over everybody as if you were growing in
years
the physical commitment that you do to
this character that was that was one of
the fun parts i feel like ava gave me so
much liberty to to experiment with the
character and it was one of the first
times i really had that opportunity um
and and so i really ran with it and i
probably pulled more than i could chew
but i remember telling her i was like
hey ava i'm gonna um i'm gonna fast for
a month before we shoot so that i can
like it look really skinny and stuff and
i'll look real young and i'll shrink my
shoulders down yes and and she was like
okay
and then i was like yeah yeah and as we
keep going i'll eat more and i'll start
working out
i just loved
uh
what you did for this important story
and may we keep telling stories in many
different forms some for escapism some
for entertainment some for education and
some for enlightenment and i think this
power peace some empowerment this
particular piece has all of the above
so thank you jaden thank you thank you
jaden michael colin in black and white
premieres october 29th on netflix
i am your biggest fan i love you so much
[Music]